I think there are many of them I know
actually my daughter is employed by a
company named myriad genetics she's in
genetics and I see a start-up that's on
exchange that hasn't made any money yet
but is growing and growing and growing
so I think there are a lot of them out
there they're not household names but
they're they're pretty exciting I think
there's a lot going on in transportation
you look at the I can't think of the
name of the little car that's coming out
that's being produced on the west coast
somebody going in the car business to
produce an eight an energy efficient car
well if you think about that I don't
think there's been a new car company
started in this country in 50 years or
something and here's somebody saying no
I got to get a better mousetrap so there
are people taking these potential
technologies and really launching
launching new businesses in a dramatic
you